c'est la première vraie bordée de neige
de l'année alors on en profite en effet
en pleine période de confinement elle a
fait le bonheur des petits et des grands
car tu t'attendais fait là on est pas
mal la maison consorts profiter de la
neige qui est tombée elle a aussi donné
du fil à retordre aux automobilistes
avec la chaussée glissante et enneigée
par endroits ils ont dû renouer avec
leurs habitudes de conduite hivernale
c'est glissant il ya pas beaucoup d
espace dans les huits si c'est bien
parce que c'est la meilleure des rues là
il faut se passer il faut savoir que
c'est la deuxième bord des neiges
conçoit cette saison on n'a pas été gâté
entre guillemets nos ventes d'essence
décembre a été pluvieux alors il faut
retrouver ses réflexes de conducteurs et
ça c'est pas ce clan chaque année
d'ailleurs la sûreté du québec a
répertorié de nombreuses sorties de
route sans incident grave
les cm qui se sont abattues dans le sud
de la province ont forcé la ville de
montréal a déclenché sa première
opération de chargement de la neige qui
sera lancée après avoir dégagé les rues
on a actuellement mais l'appareil aux
termes employés de déployer
l'idée c'était de tasser la neige des
trottoirs et des rues
d'abord au niveau des rues commerciales
qu'on appelle artérielle qui on s'en
viennent en résidentiel pour voir qu'on
a jusqu'à la fin de la journée un pur
bien tasser la neige la mise sur pause
donne un bon coup de main aux employés
municipaux déjà se déplacent moins se
visite - donc sont les véhicules vont
demeurer stationnés plus longtemps pour
l'instant c'est un facteur qui nous
aident quelques 2200 véhicules de
déneigement parcourront les rues
montréalaises dès dimanche
ici mélissa françois radio canada
montréal